It's a little daunting because it has fractions, but then when we work through it step-by-step
Hopefully, it'll feel a little bit more intuitive so it says Calvin cleans
three-fifths of his bathroom with one third of a bottle of cleaning solution at this rate
What fraction of the bottle of cleaning Solution will Calvin used to clean his entire bathroom?
And like always encourage you to pause the video and try to take a stab at this yourself
So as [I] mentioned it's a little bit
You know it's a three-fifths of his bathroom with one third of a bottle
How do we [think] about this and what my brain does is I'd like to say well
How would we like to answer the question what fraction of the bottle of cleaning solution will Calvin used to clean his entire bathroom?
So we want to figure out is we want to figure out how many bottles so??
bottles
Per let me write it this way
So we want to figure out he uses a certain number up with that?
bottles
bottles per
Bathroom if we knew this then we have the answer to the question if this would this might be I don't know [two-fifths]
Bottles two-fifths of a bottle bathroom it might be two
Bottles per bathroom, but if we know whatever this? Is and we know the answer
How many bottles doesn't need to take to clean a bathroom or what fraction of a bottle?
We don't know that they're hinting that it's a fraction of a bottle
but how much of a bottle or how many bottles per bathroom or another way to think about this if we want to know if
We wanted to express it as a as a rate more mathematically. We could say?
bottles
bottles per bathroom
Bathroom and the Reason why this is helpful
It makes it clear that look we want to figure out we want to take our
Units tell us that we want to divide the number of bottles or the fraction of a bottle it takes?
To clean the number of bathrooms or certain fraction of the bathrooms and they tell us over here they tell us that
It he's able to take one third of a bottle
He's able to take one third of a bottle so I could write it here 13
of a bottle to
clean to clean
three-fifths of a bathroom
So hopefully it's clear now. Why this was helpful? We say okay?
We want to take how many bottles it takes to clean a certain number of bathrooms one third of a bottle take can clean?
three-fifths of a bathroom and makes it clear that we need to take the one-third and
Divide it by three-fifths because then we're going to get bottles per bathroom. We're going to get the rate
We're not going to get bathrooms per bottle we're going to get bottles per bathroom
Which is what we care about what fraction of the bottle well?
It will it take to clean entire bathroom to clean one entire bathroom?
So now we just have to take one-third and divide it by three-fifths
So this is going to be equal to this is going to be equal to you can write it this way
three-fifths
Divided by three fifths and the units are going to be bottles per bathroom. I'll write it like that
Bottles or since if we know that that's going to be a fraction. We could just say rate bottle bathroom bottle
Bathroom and so this is going to be the same thing as well
we're going to have one third divided by three fifths is the same thing as
One-Third times the reciprocal of three fifths so one-third times five thirds
one-Third times five thirds
Bottle bathroom, so let me write that down bottle
bathroom
Bottle bathroom and what is this going to be well?
We multiply the numerators 1 times 5 is going to give us 5 and the denominator three times three is nights?
There's going to be five ninths of a bottle of a bottle
bathroom
Bathroom I wrote these a little bit further apart than I would want to let me write that a little bit closer together
59 59 of a bottle
bathroom
So just as a reminder of what we did here
It could see him a little bit daunting
But we said okay look he we want how much I'm what fraction of the bottle to clean his entire bathroom
So we care about bottles per bathroom or since we're talking about a fraction
I guess we could just say bottle some fraction of a bottle per bathroom so it's bottle
Bathrooms that's going to give us the correct rate
So it took one third of a bottle to clean
Three-fifths of a bathroom so you divide one third by three-fifths?
You get five ninths of a bottle per bathroom, so this? Right over here that is
59 it takes five ninths of a bottle of cleaning solution to clean his entire bathroom